Ugh, the holidays!
On Thanksgiving, Americans gather to break
bread and share what they’re grateful for.
But what should you do if you don’t feel
thankful?
Maybe your boss is a jerk.
Maybe money is tight.
Maybe you’re dreading awkward political
arguments with your relatives.
Whatever the reason, you’re not feeling
the holiday spirit – so what are you supposed
to do?
Three words: Act grateful anyway.
Social science shows that choosing to practice
gratitude, no matter how you feel, can itself
make you more grateful – and happier, too.
One 2003 study found that people who kept
a list of things they were grateful for were
significantly more satisfied with their lives
than subjects who dwelled on negative, or
even neutral, events instead.
And thankfulness is contagious.
A 2011 study found that responding to an angry
person with warmth and gratitude disarms their
aggression and leads to better behavior.
So here’s the prescription for the holiday
blues: Forget about your feelings, and decide
to count your blessings.
It’ll make you a happier person.
And it’ll probably make your dinner companions
happier, too.
What do you think about the research on gratitude?
Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you’d
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.